bonjour aujourd'hui j'ai envie de faire
plein de choses extraordinaires
lui est là bonjour julien bonjour
quasiment faux gentil fait un peu moins
de bruit s'il te plaît mais enfin
pourquoi vous y compris mademoiselle
futile dans le petit bois et tu as peur
qu'un si elle m'entend elles viennent
embêter mais pas du tout je n'avais pas
vu d'aujourd'hui et je me repose un peu
comment tu te reposes alors que moi je
viens de me lever et tant pis pour toi
tu avais 4 lever plus tôt
tu m'aurais aider à ranger mon qu'est-ce
que je serai moins fatigués bon tu es
vraiment pas drôle pour moi je vais voir
en fois très bonne idée
france soir
ok j'ai mieux que tu pourrais pas crié
un petit peu moins fort s'il te plait je
ne crie pas plus apte alors s'il te
plaît je suis choqué un petit peu moins
forts jugé très fatigué fatigué c'est
quand même pas en nettoyant des ballons
bon ben écoute casimir si tu veux tout
savoir ce matin j'ai dû me lever très
tôt afin d'étudier voilà enfin là moi je
suis en pleine forme et prêt à rendre
service à tout le monde
vous êtes tous les deux et puiser pour
tout le monde
mademoiselle de facteurs c'est vous qui
avez commandé ces bonbons je pense oui
oui poser le coq et la sig les facteurs
cela paraît manquer ce que tout à
l'heure je me pose un peu pendant nous
avions de la chance
moi aussi je suis fatigué seulement je
n'ai pas le temps de me reposer
vous avez peut-être trop travailler vous
aussi à parlons-en casimir c'est la
faute de ton cousin théodule quoi mon
cousin théodule enfin mon cousin perdu
il ya quinze jours qu'il a quitté l'île
a justement et il est parti en emportant
une liste d'objets commandé par tous les
gens de l'île aux enfants et au lieu de
renvoyer un colis à chacun il a tout mis
dans le même et à mon nom
le résultat il faut que je trouve moi
même le destinataire de chaque colis et
que je le lui porte
ouais ouais ouais c'est sain c'est quoi
un destinataire
enfin kazemi en chine à terre celui qui
est qui qui attendent un colis
auquel est destiné un colis tandis que
l'expéditeur vois tu sais celui hockey
et qui expédie un colis qui envoie un
colis voilà tu vois casimir ce paquet
j'en suis le destinant pauvres voilà oui
par exemple un autre destinataire on va
écouter ça va j'ai compris je ne suis
quand même pas complètement idiot
rabreau pardonne-moi casimir est plus tu
sais j'ai pas le temps plus orienté
voilà je vais arranger ça puisque c'est
mon cousin théodule qui a fait une
bêtise il est normal que ce soit moi
casimir son cousin il a réparé vraiment
casimir
mais comment peux tu mets des étoiles
bien vous avez apporté ici tous les
colis et que j'irai distribué à chaque à
chaque destinataire le frein ok tu
ferais ça poursuit casimir à puisque tu
es prêt à me rendre service je veux bien
que tu te moques un petit peu de moi
bon alors tu m' attends je reviens je
vais aller chercher le colis a tout de
suite d'accord bon moi je vais commencer
à préparer mon stand j'appellerai mon
entreprise je vais commencer après